[Music]
ellen degeneres
what is she getting the cancel well
because i heard so that's actually what
this video is about i didn't hear
it's all on rumors so no no
no actual facts in this but there's
rumors
that telepictures said
that ellen is ready to just
cancel the show she's just like you know
what she should [ __ ] it her
nugget herschel well remember like
mom like pre-corona right didn't she go
well if
it first started with her being in a
photo with george bush right yeah and
then later
there were a lot of interns and people
toxic workplace
yeah that were coming out against yeah
and youtuber came out as well
yeah oh yeah yeah and how they were
treated nikki and so like
i didn't know that recently it kept
going on
because i don't know who it was was it
oh i think it was kevin hart
who recently made a post and then
they're talking about how like
like she's my friend and the [ __ ] that
she's going through right now it sucks
and i'm like wait they're still going
afterwards oh yeah they're still going
live celebrities standing by ellen
apparently a lot of her staff
were getting sexually harassed yeah and
there was nothing being done about it
like
the top top producer guys dozens were
being dudes
and ellen apparently everyone knew kind
of thing and nobody did anything about
like the weinstein
who's harassing she's the one harassing
her no no no
her top producer guys like the exact
producer guys apparently allegedly
you know what sucks though is like why
okay like i cuz i know people that own
companies right and a lot of the times
the managers really [ __ ] [ __ ] up
right and yes the ceos and the owners
should know but a lot of the times
they're blindsided and they're like
what the [ __ ] happened sure saying this
to the what and then like
and then so like in this case right i'm
not even protecting ellen or whatever
but i can kind of see how like
in an organization it is extremely
difficult
to see everything that's going on
and when there are people that [ __ ] [ __ ]
up
why can't we put that individual on
on the on the on the what do you call it
like on trial
like sometimes the ceo or the is an
innocent bystander like they're doing
their best
and then they don't even hear whatever
is going on and then like someone gets
hit
like the ceo gets hit because some
[ __ ] like rubbed up somebody
well the idea here is that people there
was an understanding
like the ecosystem like weinstein yeah
yeah yeah oh and everyone kind of knew
behind the scenes and nobody did [ __ ]
all about oh
[ __ ] yeah so so they're saying that
ellen knew
they're saying that ellen ellen must
have been aware or some kind of [ __ ]
who knows i'm not saying it's [ __ ]
i'm saying who knows what it was
there's also people saying like this one
quote says the fish rots from the head
and ellen is the head so no matter what
was happening
whether or not like she chose the wrong
managers she's a bad yeah yeah
it's her responsibility no matter what
it's her show
she runs the show she created this
environment she is responsible
and so that's why a lot of people are
not being lenient with her and that's
why she's getting caught in this
and all this drama right now that's why
oprah's getting [ __ ] about weinstein too
even though they weren't even
in a company together but they they're
like buddies they're buds and like
apparently oprah and everybody [ __ ]
knew about weinstein nobody did anything
about nobody gave a [ __ ] and so it's
it's just another one of those things
even i knew about weinstein
before people knew about like we had
friends that worked around kevin spacey
i remember talking about kim spacey in
this room before it all
came out you heard a rumor about him
being uh yeah
really yeah i had a friend we had a
friend that like knew
kevin spacey was like like was gay and
like was
yeah i forgot who it was someone in this
room said
something and then like a year two years
later it came out
and then i remembered like wait i
already know this information oh sure
yeah yeah we knew years ago before
i knew who weinstein was like my i like
my like i knew his
like pictures right but i didn't know
who he was like as a big producer
until our friend had an interaction with
them in asia
and one of his actors had a private time
with them she came downstairs and said
[ __ ] that guy he tried to [ __ ]
like do [ __ ] to me really he might get
this role if we
do it and it's like i'm not gonna work
with this [ __ ] whoa and he was like
[ __ ] and then so because he did a lot of
uh uh
work in asia and he brought a lot of
films to america
yeah so this was 2008 maybe when we got
this information
and that was my introduction to who
harvey weinstein was yeah and then there
could be people that
might take what we're saying now and be
like really you knew so long why don't
you say anything and it's like well
what can you do based off of rumors so i
think like once you're so far removed
it's like
she said she said she said yeah it's a
hearsay story yeah exactly
like even what we're hearing about like
i remember we were talking about we've
talked about the only thing before and
it's like
hearing people say she wasn't that nice
to me it's a totally different thing
than like she was
part of an environment that's like all
this sexual harassment's happening and
she's just chilling
yeah man the sexual harassment stuff
says 36
former employees uh that spoke to
buzzfeed news and a lot of them said
that
there was the sexual misconduct
harassment and assault
damn yeah and so that they would report
it
and like nothing would happen and
everyone's like and whatever like one
example says
this one ex-employee described seeing
one of the executive producers
grab the penis of a production assistant
whoa
that's pretty bold yeah and then another
one said that they witnessed
that same person grow a production
assistant inside a vehicle and kiss his
neck
so i'm like what it's not easy to grab a
dick too
cause you gotta know where it's at first
because like you know like
you know like boobs are kind of out
there butts out there
but a dick you gotta find they could be
going left you're going right yeah if
they're wearing khakis it's almost
protected well it's not that hard to
find i mean just go
through the general area and it could be
very hard to find most
oh that sucks yeah that sucks for not
you
well if you're wearing khakis right and
they're all tight you grab it and it's
just gonna be grabbing a wall or no
pants
this happened to brendan fraser brendan
frazier was at a hollywood
thing and a huge mega hollywood producer
apparently
came up and groped him really yeah that
would terry crew said as well
terry crews said the same thing yeah so
yeah if people if you're if you're
like brendan fraser's level he was like
a-list like star of multiple things yeah
mummy franchise if you can get groped at
a hollywood party
anybody anybody can can be it's like
crazy the part that i don't understand
that i'm trying to defend or anything
but like so i get it the
fish rise from the head right but if
someone groped you like one of the
producers
why report it to ellen why not get the
cops
you know what i mean like it's like it's
almost like let's say in this company
like let's say if if i stole from casey
what's the point of casey reporting to
joe about me because
why don't you just call the cops and i
get arrested because then you get
arrested
and then you tell your powerful friends
not to hire you or not to hire casey and
then casey doesn't get hired anymore
and so that's kind of what people bumped
up against was like who do i go to and
even the cops situation
you think cops are were going to up to
harvey weinstein about rape allegations
they didn't give a [ __ ] that's true it's
not like working at mcdonald's or
carl's jr where like you do call the
cops
if your co-worker steals or or whatever
if a crime was committed there's no
incentive for them not to bust you yeah
because
you're not going to be kicked out of the
burger industry exactly you'll go
like we'll be like [ __ ] you i'll go to
[ __ ] taco bell then i'll work there
right right
but then like in hollywood there is this
black listing that happens
it's a small industry and there's skin
in the game there's skin in the game the
cops have an incentive to protect these
people
because funding leaks down from all
areas don't they actually work
in the film industry too absolutely you
see cops like blocking off streets for
the film crew
thank you lapd at the end of a movie
like you see all this kind of [ __ ] you
see
them thinking the defense department
sometimes like it's all pervasive
crazy did you know in harvey weinstein's
contract
if you read his contracts there's
literally
how many times he gets fined for
scandals and [ __ ] up and [ __ ] like
that
because they knew his his behavior
dude insurance is like that they they
have it they have like sexual harassment
insurance even in hollywood
they knew that he's gonna sexually
harass a woman
so they wrote it in the [ __ ] contract
what did they write exactly
i don't know what the exact words are
but people were basically talking about
how
like he would have stipulations like if
you
if you if this breaks out or like if you
get into some kind of like sexual
harassment or whatever
then we will find you x amount of
dollars oh so like compensate or fine
what do you mean like he will get
charged for those things yeah yeah
so during this production let's say you
sexually harass a woman
um not in those words obviously but it's
like pretty much
saying like if you fall into this here's
the slap on the wrist
yeah it's like so by the third time it's
like eight million dollars or whatever
and it's like who [ __ ] writes that
that's
like that's not a standard hollywood
contract evil people dude it's in
congress too there's a congressional
fund where congress people of both
parties
all houses they sexually harass their
pages who are like their interns
and their production assistants and
there is just a fund that exists it's
all taxpayer-funded and they just take
from that fund and just pay off the
abused
and then all that [ __ ] gets wiped from
the front page is because even the media
doesn't give a [ __ ] because they're all
like the media needs their ecosystem of
stories sourced by these people
so it's all [ __ ] bro because for them
it's really about like
hey what's better do we pay off these
people
and keep it under the rug or we all get
a bad rep
because we look like the whole industry
yeah i think with power
i mean we saw that with the catholic
church right like for them
it it's like we can't taint our image
let's just hide this
versus let's be honorable about it and
be like yeah this guy did what he did
like
let's let's all shun him for it it's
like no no there's nothing happening
here
right same with hollywood like if if
harvey weinstein's
producing mad [ __ ] films and money
and he's winning all these awards it's
kind of like
let's protect the golden goose he's
making us
billions of [ __ ] money right so what
if a few people get [ __ ]
that's literally what these psychopaths
are thinking so here we are right
entertainment hollywood and politics
all at the top all [ __ ] like where do
you
run to what bart's question where do you
run to to call the police
yeah like in one industry because even
police
are getting um silenced like there's a
lot there's a list of whistleblowing
police
that they would get like for example in
the epstein thing right the
the the i don't know if it's tampa bay
but whatever florida
agency they had no [ __ ] idea about
the whole
epson thing or or whatever a girl is
west palm beach west palm beach a girl
escaped it right and they started to
legitimately investigate it
they did a full-on investigation they
have all the pages ready you can read it
it's [ __ ] up right but they got
silenced by
their department and the and people
above so they did their job
yeah it's [ __ ] nuts damn so that just
means the
people at the very very tippity top of
it all
are the ones that are like the worst
[ __ ] predators everywhere because
they're silencing everyone else that
wants to like attack the predator like
no no that's one of them that's one of
mine
that's what people are saying right when
they say the culture of something like
it creates a culture that allows blah
like that's what this is yeah but what's
wild
is that it's so hard to remember all
this stuff because so much else gets
pushed out there so it's like
yes they covered it but then it kind of
goes away after a while yeah
because there's so many things right and
then it's like we're picking the wrong
leaders like it's not ellen
you know it's not it's not just ellen
yeah it's not
weinstein yeah it's the culture of
hollywood
and the producers the the people don't
know these guys names
the protection racks the guys that are
[ __ ] raking in billions
no one knows their names it's the same
in all industries and in the real
leaders like ellen's real boss real yeah
it's not her it's her real [ __ ] boss
yeah she's just a puppet in the game
yeah but everyone's pointing at it like
see these are these examples i mean who
was les moonves right he was the head of
cbs
and he went down for sexual harassment
like same [ __ ] he was the head of cbs
for like 25 years but they're ceos and
people don't know that ceos
are just very expensive managers
they don't own [ __ ] and they probably
think like oh if we if
they go down then everyone will forget
and think that the
they're not even the head of the snake
resolved and then we're good
google let's move is his wife she's a
she was a [ __ ] news anchor for years
no she she holds big brother still was
it no no but what i'm saying is
is that so here you are you work at cvs
like well here's somebody who's in
journalism i can go to them
and maybe i can get help and it's the
wife of the person who's like
in charge of the whole [ __ ] thing
scary scary thing i don't know who to go
to
yeah ghostbusters hey oh that's it
twitter bro ghostbusters
[Music]
[Music]
you